i grew up seeing the impacts of climate  change firsthand  having to be afraid of drowning in my  own bedroom and  sometimes waking up in the middle of the  night with flood water in my room and  having to scoop it out  cold and dark and afraid  growing up i would go to strangers  and talk to them about greenhouse gas  emissions and global warming in the  ozone layer  because climate education in the  philippines is so  lacking i didn't even make the  connection between the typhoons i was  already experiencing and the  greenhouse gas emissions i was talking  about we needed  an organization that specifically talked  about the climate and so  me and my friends we decided to put up  youth advocates for climate action  philippines  i realized that i have no choice i have  to join the struggle of our  environmental defenders and of the  people for a better planet a better  future  a safe presence i had to join the fight